[Music]
[Applause]
these words of sir william osler are
especially true of late syphilis
each case presents a complicated problem
of diagnosis and treatment
one of the most common late skin lesions
is the nodular ulcerate of syphilis
this lesion consists of nodules which
progress to ulceration
they often arrange themselves in circles
or arcs
such lesions result in scars
characterized by the fact that they do
not contract
the cirpidginous syphilid is
characterized by its snake-like border
with slight atrophy and scaling within
the arcs
osteochondritis of the nasal structures
may result only in perforation of the
septal in collapse of the bridge of the
nose producing the well-known saddle
nose
this is more frequent in congenital than
in acquired syphilis
perforation of the palate is not
frequent but should be looked for
most cases of osseous syphilis come to
treatment before the condition is this
far advanced
x-ray examination helps to establish the
diagnosis
in the absence of clinical signs and
symptoms involvement of the central
nervous system can be detected only by
examination of the spinal fluid
even if clinical signs are present the
diagnosis cannot be certain without
confirmation by spinal fluid examination
every patient receiving anti-syphilitic
treatment should be subjected to this
examination before being discharged
since involvement of the central nervous
system is the most frequent cause of
resistance to treatment
the technique of spinal puncture can be
learned only by supervised experience
examination of the spinal fluid should
include serologic test
cell count globulin and colloidal test
the serologic test and cell count are
the most important spinal fluid
examination should be used to confirm
such clinical diagnosis as general
parasites tabies and meningovascular
syphilis
general paris however is a psychiatric
diagnosis the signs include change in
personality neuroscenic symptoms such as
depression or relation lack of judgment
confusion of ideas impaired memory and
slurred speech
tell me
lovely lily
lemon lovely lily lehman hundred percent
truly rural fully proved in america
truly rural through a little liquid
electricity liquid exchange
patient may exhibit hyperactive reflexes
unless tabi's is superimposed
when tabi's dorsalis is present however
the patellar reflexes are diminished or
absent
and the pupils usually do not react to
light
in advanced cases of tabies the gate is
characteristic of that resulting from
degeneration of the posterior columns of
the spinal cord
the romberg test is positive
sphincter control may be lost optic
atrophy may be associated with tabies or
it may be the only clinical sign of
central nervous system involvement
paralysis of the extra ocular muscles
may occur in meningovascular syphilis or
the paralysis may strike other parts of
the body
involvement of the extraocular muscles
is common
in cardiovascular syphilis the disease
most often strikes the aorta and the
aortic valve
aneurysm as here illustrated develops
from simple aortitis
syphilitic involvement of the aortic
valve is characterized by an early
diastolic murmur in the aortic area
such a murmur when not accompanied by
mitral disease usually indicates
syphilitic involvement of the heart
many symptoms of syphilitic involvement
of the cardiovascular system such as
dyspnea on exertion are identical with
symptoms produced by other cardiac
conditions
most characteristic of this condition
however is paroxysmal dyspnea without
exertion and associated with a sense of
constriction across the chest
uncomplicated syphilitic aortitis is
very difficult to diagnose
many cases pass rigid physical
examinations without detection
look for history of circulatory
embarrassment progressive cardiac
failure
substernal pain and paroxysmal dyspnea
look for x-ray evidence of aortic
dilatation
look for increased width of the area of
dullness to percussion at the base of
the heart
listen for a tambour accentuation of the
second aortic sound
it sounds like this
such a tone quality of the second aortic
sound in the presence of late syphilis
suggests here titus
are cynical drugs are dangerous in
cardiovascular syphilis prepare such
patients with bismuth for three or four
months before giving arsenic
since many cases of uncomplicated
syphilitic aortitis pass unrecognized it
is best to start treatment with bismuth
in all cases where the duration of the
infection is more than five years
congenital syphilis frequently causes an
osteochondritis of the nasal bones which
later produces a profile like this
also the teeth of the second dentition
are frequently deformed in the manner
described by hutchinson
interstitial keratitis is more common in
congenital syphilis than in acquired
syphilis
it may appear anytime from childhood to
adult life
and if not properly treated continues to
recur and may eventually lead to
blindness
deafness is a frequent manifestation of
late congenital syphilis and is quite
resistant to treatment
spinal fluid examination is just as
important in congenital syphilis as in
acquired syphilis
juvenile parasite starts at about the
age of puberty it can be prevented
examine the spinal fluid at four years
of age or as soon thereafter as
congenital syphilis is
discovered all syphilitic infections are
latent at some time during their course
all syphilitic infections are latent
most of the time
from the disappearance of the primary
and secondary manifestations until the
ultimate breakdown of the patient
to prevent the tragedies of late
syphilis take routine blood tests on all
patients
when a routine blood test is reported
positive a complete history and physical
examination are indicated
the physician should inquire into
history of genital lesions skin
eruptions and other indications of
primary and secondary syphilis
a history of prolonged sore throat
especially in the absence of rhinitis is
suggested
inquire whether there is a history of
previous blood tests or injections in
the arm or hip
if there is no history indicative of
acquired syphilis ask about symptoms of
congenital syphilis in the patient and
in his brothers and sisters
ask about symptoms of syphilis in the
patient's father and mother
note the causes of death of deceased
parents
for the physical examination natural
daylight is preferable to artificial
light
inspect all portions of the skin
carefully in good light
note particularly the palms of the hands
and the soles of the feet
palpate the lymph nodes to detect
enlargements
inspect the hair for patchy alopecia
look for iritis and muscular palsies and
test the pupillary reflexes
inspect the eye grounds for power of the
optic discs and for choreo retinitis
look for split papules at the angles of
the nose and mucous patches within
is the septum perforated
look for split papules at the angles of
the lips and mucous patches in the mouth
and pharynx
perform an otoscopic examination
routinely
pulsation in the suprasternal notch
would suggest an aortic aneurysm
in an asymptomatic case look carefully
for signs of cardiovascular syphilis
examine the lungs as a routine procedure
test the deep reflexes and perform a
romberg test
in the abdominal examination look for
enlargement of liver and spleen
masses or other pathology
look for moist papules and mucous
patches
and for evidence of gonorrhea
remember that cervical shankers may be
manifested only by diffuse induration of
the cervix
a syphilitic infection may be considered
latent if a thorough physical
examination and the spinal fluid
examination both yield negative results
late syphilis results from untreated
latent syphilis thus latent syphilis
presents a challenge to which the
logical answer is mass blood testing
to prevent the tragedy of late syphilis
we cannot sit back and wait for patients
to report to treatment sources
perform blood tests on industrial youth
military and other population groups at
every opportunity
examine the families of patients who are
discovered to have syphilis
examine extramarital sexual contacts of
known cases
perform blood tests on all hospital and
office patients routinely
and now we're ready for the blood test
mrs hamilton
this is a routine procedure which i
perform on all of my patients
i've found from my experience that
syphilis is no respecter of persons and
it often strikes without one's knowing
it
but i feel certain
that the report we receive
will be reassuring to both of us
what if the report is positive
does a single positive laboratory report
prove the presence of syphilis
no
one should first rule out the
possibility of technical error or
biologically false reaction
three procedures are essential to the
establishment or exclusion of syphilis
in the patient on whom a positive blood
test has been obtained by routine
examination
the first of these is a thorough and
careful family history and history of
past illnesses and complaints
the second is a careful and detailed
physical examination
the third is a check of the original
positive blood report with additional
tests performed in reliable laboratories
if the blood test reports on the history
and physical examination are not
definite and consistent perform a spinal
fluid examination before discharging the
patient as non-syphilitic
treatment for syphilis should not be
started until the presence of syphilis
has been definitely established
anti-syphilitic treatment is not without
danger
its hazard should not be accepted
lightly
if the physician with all available
information at hand is still in doubt as
to whether the patient does or does not
have syphilis he should request
consultation with a specialist
in many parts of the country such
consultation service is available
through the county city or state health
department
to keep abreast of current developments
in the diagnosis treatment and public
health aspects of syphilis read venereal
disease information one of the medical
journals published by the united states
public health service
[Music]
[Applause]
you